à saint quentin en yvelines +2 50% des
médecins généralistes vont partir à la
retraite dans les prochaines années pour
pallier la désertification médicale sur
son territoire l'agglomération a signé
son deuxième contrat local de santé avec
ses partenaires notamment l' agence
régionale de santé et la préfecture des
yvelines travailler vraiment l'offre de
soins former des médecins faire en sorte
que des médecins qui les jeunes médecins
les étudiants en médecine de
l'université qu'ils puissent rester sur
le territoire qu'ils puissent exercer
sur le territoire il ya une centaine de
professionnels de santé qui va falloir
faire venir sur le territoire dans les
cinq 5 à 7 ans à venir
une signature qui se tenait à l'occasion
du premier salon du bien-être organisé
par l'agglomération
une quarantaine d'exposants étaient
présents à la ferme du manet comme cette
maison des géants pour prévenir les
risques domestiques ou cet atelier pour
réaliser son propre dentifrice l'argile
rêvant d'être un petit peu et j'en
mettais beaucoup argile blanche de
carbonate de soude quelques gouttes
d'huiles essentielles et un peu d'eau
des ingrédients naturels
on utilise tous au quotidien que ce soit
ça avant shampoing maquillage dentifrice
et des produits compte six au quotidien
et idc d'essayer de creuser un peu voilà
on les utilise mais qu'est-ce qui a
concrètement à l'intérieur développer la
connaissance
/
le domaine de la prévention pour les
enfants pour les sensibiliser
sensibilisés à l'environnement et puis
la santé très important selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
plupart des maladies chroniques comme le
diabète ou certains cancers seraient
directement liées à nos modes de vie
pour sa première édition ce salon a
attiré plus de 500 visiteurs